my mom would never let me have candy
because I'm an athlete which means I'm
supposed to be having healthy stuff I've
never had candy because my mom sometimes
she yeah a little bit of a control freak
because my parents think I'm gonna get
cavity probably because I don't like
them honestly I hate fruit anything
fruit flavored I won't go near this
could be my chance to have as much as
candy Iceland hot to my dearest cinnamon
I just need to do an inspection oh gosh
oh oh this is hot
plus one tribe just tastes like sugar
for this not to read by it looks like a
like a Christmas evening here's a little
glisten mmm
no flavored rubber but I'm like a
buttery finger by Nestle Chris Spedding
crunch Eddie peanut butter no artificial
flavors or colors I'm blown over did
your bub tastes like a peanut crunch it
doesn't make me want a peanut butter fan
fun nip cherry yum Dibley dick for this
little packet it says there's 45
calories I have a hard time believing
that we're really good that when I eat
it feels like I'm eating chalk using
something that sugar and is dipping it
in sugar so it's just double the amount
of toxic weight and kids eat this for
pleasure
dude I can smell it from here
I feel like I took scare my tone Oh more
height okay I'm just trying to see like
little here's me other fingers was
really crunchy and delicious
I don't like delish some of it was good
some it wasn't but I think it was not
terrible